hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to Bad
Kitty
[Music]
we all know Bill Murray duped himself in
the Garfield one thing you want the Coen
brothers wrote it but his contract
included a sequel and because audiences
love to see this man punished
he got one Garfield the tale of two
kitties continues the Garfield movie
tradition of having practically nothing
to do with Garfield she dances has a ton
of energy tries to help those in need
and was like a hairy hallucination from
Pink Floyd's the wall but he liked
lasagna so no different probably goes
without saying that this film is just a
status first but this is an analytical
review series so just saying lightning
you quantum your pubic hair
probably isn't going to be enough so
let's take a look with greater detail
something the filmmakers obviously
didn't do this is Garfield a tale of two
kitties so the only figure is the
opening would be in cram it just assume
the whole script was or a minute still
starts off with a surprising narration
from Roscoe Lee Brown the narrator babe
once upon a time in an English castle
there lived a pampered personage home
not off the elegance of dignity
you Garfield oh please you no other life
in a life of luxury oh did I mention
that cringe sort of care yes
I'm kind of a bad narrator oh did I also
mention that takes place in the year 50
21 so you can quickly imagine this cat
named Prince looks exactly like Garfield
that is obviously taking influence from
Mark Twain's The Prince and the pauper
yes that's so
why is your title satirizing A Tale of
Two Cities if it's why did the opening
credits at fairy tales none of these
things are connected this is what to do
a garfield then the rest of the movie is
anything to do with Garfield we men see
our main character Garfield who's pretty
athletic for being so heavy you guys
don't know what a cat
right as he discovers his master John is
going to propose to Liz the vet who
Garfield apparently doesn't like
whatever happened to John my metalhead
guy my dad you were so much cooler when
you wore a mullet
now that's suggesting that John had a
mullet did he listen drops his big
question because apparently she's been
invited to go to England to speak at the
Royal animal convergence II Jane Goodall
dropped out at the last minute because
she's nursing a sick chimp and they
asked me not yes Jane Goodall Liz the
vet I totally understand this choice
that's like saying what we can't get
rudy giuliani to open the 9/11 museum
we'll bring in paul blart mall cop
that's a fitting replacement we do this
smart ding you moron John decides to
follow Liz to England where we see the
owner of Princess died and so let's try
Stephen Colbert reach the will saying
who gets what I leave all my worldly
possessions to my beloved Kitty Prince
the twelve i crimps the new lord of the
castle that's right legality be damned
captain now own property and title ship
come on is it anyone would be stupid
enough to give uncontrollable power to a
dumb orange narcissus with no experience
whatsoever well you know they did I
imagine his inauguration would be about
this big I pledge from this day forward
to rule my kingdom with wisdom and valor
in case you're wondering that Tim Curry
providing the voice of Prince which is a
shame because I really think it's
accepted species a little bit more than
curry ask even now the evil feed of what
you've done
germinates within you I require the
solace of the shadows and the dark of
the night
sunshine is my this dryer
we are all animals have a lovely day a
princes rule upsets the original owners
nephew darkness played by Billy Connolly
who was very clearly chosen because John
Cleese wouldn't do it don't get me wrong
I love Billy Connolly but it's amazing
how much they make him look sound and
act exactly like John Cleese since he is
gone the title of the Carlyle estate
falls to me chicken gold under a 20-foot
pile of horseshit well actually it's
quite common now I don't need to meet
this yet I don't particularly care what
it seems to you my mom it's the same
character cliff usually plays aim
attitude appearance and voice I'm just
imagining that recording of John Cui's
burning does roll down I focus West
Evans Christmas adventures won't rent us
but I've drawn the line at the tail two
kitties actually if two kitties I know
what I said now if you'll excuse me I'm
off to film The Adventures of Pluto Nash
over our movie a proud family oh thanks
so what place is enjoying his continue
with life of luxury Jesus Christ I
thought those were sweetheart
Connolly decides it's all water under
the bridge by placing prints in water
under the bridge so the animals try to
foil whatever Connolly's evil plans are
that season you wouldn't want to injure
the creatures would you no no only aim
for the orange ones with celebrities
mumbling swear words under their breath
Oh Garfield asides while in Britain he
should probably look around first let's
grab some Chow before I eat your liver
with some fava beans and a nice Chianti
why do best sequels think kids have seen
Silence of the Lambs
do they plan on Cartoon Network did you
a crossover with gumball but one of the
butler's comes across Garfield
of course mistaking him for Prince while
plans is in a nearby sewer come on I'm
gonna help with Jack
I'm in the sewer oh come on you have a
Silence of the Lambs joking you have Tim
Curry in a sewer and you don't do this
hi Georgie lay low okay yeah yeah I must
return to my threaten one here ha
how come every animal in this movie can
talk but you it didn't make sense in the
comic strip either is anything in this
movie improved on that time for you
bloody well that's the best news I've
had all day
it does not very bright is he where are
you taking me is it somewhere lovely you
know I understand that the humans can't
hear the animals in this but do they
ever question why many of them have
spastic movements that be eerily similar
to human conversations what is it
dealing with human attributes well this
just seems totally normal to me should I
be concerned
oh I know I'll use my feline with human
attributes translator still not talking
this was something just kept dude no no
no no no we communicate just fine
she is just having a stroke come along
darling we'll get you to a doctor
yeah take her to Liz the vet I hear
she's a next-gen good old it looks like
he was found just in time as cuddly has
evil plans to turn the giant estate into
a spa actually that sounds lovely
meditation garden and of course luxury
condominium those widow's chase off
little serve up to the guests
okay the animal thing is douchey but
with financial planners I'm sure they
find a way to either make profit on the
farm or sell the animals in a way that
would also make them profit I mean
what's the alternative there's just a
big house for a cat call me crazy but I
totally siding with the bad guy in this
doing something with that place make it
more than just a very expensive litter
box what screw that instead we have to
have Garfield fitted for print so that
the estate can continue to burn money
hungry
oh yes attention animals I can sense
things through smell here is an obvious
imposter fall for it darkest can't
bulldoze the barnyard and fingers to the
Germans destroyed you'll have to deal
with each sister fury buddies yeah he'll
have to put up with our blank stares
endure how unfocused we all are but
Garfield is show that him staying there
is very important unfairly the feline
inbreeding your Celtic that there's
literally not one difference in between
them let's get a house inside oh hey the
guys on the far chilled much lower than
I originally expected Leawood well
struck sauna good tone smooth finish
Oh Jim Davis reacted after seeing his
creation destroy but held a big residual
check at the same time I got me online
the Garfield enjoys the palace life
again getting more exercise than we have
ever seen this character get it doesn't
even question the scary of Hell singing
paintings your cat you know he's
frightening enough in kind of three
dimensions we don't need to see if he's
that frightening you do but Connelly
after a pretty long period of time
passes finally discovers that the cat is
still there bring some of those
investors those lovely investors of all
parties here you hope see a green screen
of England if you know we haven't had a
sunny day and he on cue we train the dog
to rip Garfield to shreds but it seems
to back
is not supposed to be a prog-rock not
castration just like it came up Rose
death
meanwhile print is being forced to enjoy
a common life while still be mistaken
for Garfield and good know what gruel is
this British food so I understand the
comparison
[Music]
later in the day with who went to deadly
take the tour of the palace Garfield is
it I'm a shock to you if I be uh one
question not Vettel is oh thank God we
got rid of that good old bitch you're
the real connection to the animal mind
what would you say if I were to delay it
to one of my priceless oil paintings
that royal sleaze is hitting on Liz the
person I was trying to keep out of my
life and now he suddenly care about for
no reason
transitions are it smooth there's a slip
and slide becoming a flippin sandpaper
you moron Connolly throw them in the
dungeon but an animal friends are there
to help him get up what you finally hear
my stomach growl yeah but we heard your
choice um mother look could you have a
bigger role on uh how exactly does this
dungeon work you pull on the chains like
anyone would do in a dungeon especially
you're gonna Hank up somebody and that
opens a way out kind of
counterproductive isn't doom oh there
was a setup like that haha five minutes
back girl this whole room will do it
laughing gasps better figure a way out
of you wanna battle
outside the dungeon Garfield finally
comes face-to-face with a mirror in the
garden of wha you know this is usually
more impressive when people are doing it
you know instead of animated vomit
stains that you can move however you
want to people moving in exact unison is
very impressive but when one anime
cartoon moves exactly like the other
animated cartoon it just kind of looks
like you're copying it what's that movie
oh yes of course
it looks so realistic I didn't even know
it was CG how many just use that as an
excuse but one Prince returns it looks
like he just wants to run away from
connolly garfield again in typical
garfield fashion applies his bravery and
self motivation to inspire the others
you know I have to believe we can do
better we don't leave we stand and we
kick royal but is it really that hard to
open one of these but this movie's not
done trying to be the next Santa Paws as
all the animals come together to foil
Connolly's plans to risk a No yeah you
never know when you might need a maze
gonna have those lying around that must
been great on those tours we see all the
time feel free to touch the maze take
one home as a souvenir it's a great form
of punishment if you can't you on this
movie after the animals give Connolly
the runaround he take measures into his
own hands
let it go all in good time
no not Liz she was gonna cure animal
transfer Oh one weasel bites off another
weasel the point we know there's nothing
left up there and everybody seems to be
safe I've been trying to get the courage
up to ask you something all week we
looking for something Liz remarry me
yes marriage that's what this was all
about
Garfield getting over his hatred of Liz
and his love for John by being separated
from them in most of the movie learning
at the loose quanti the creditor around
the corner oh wow it's like the next
scene
this movie wants to end itself as much
as I do so that was the prince in the
I mean furry tail theater I mean a
tale of two kitties yep seriously why is
the cold out again she pretends to be
funny moralistic and just like our field
but it's all unfocused on the message
and has more to do with dental surgery
than garfi and it's probably more
tolerable to sister thank god there's
only two of these movies because they
only will gotten worse and worse they
start from a place that had little to do
with such a likable character and only
strayed further and further away my
advice is not to look at any of this
kitty litter anytime soon and that's the
last movie for a sequel month and thank
God can you think of anything good this
experience has given us hmm
bill he's always been here how could you
forget
[Music]
you moron
hey dub Walker here doing the charity
shout-out and this week we are doing the
wounded warriors family support their
mission is to provide support to the
families of those who have been wounded
injured or killed during combat
operations the families of their
casualty suffering many ways some
financially some psychologically they're
focused on so many different elements
like to promote and support philanthropy
through a program that is effective in
providing all federal employees the
opportunity to improve the quality of
life for all the great thing is you can
see the families they help out as well
as hear the amazing things these brave
soldiers did on both their website and
their YouTube channel you can see how
this unbelievable bravery should and is
being rewarded at least with your help
take a look at all the sacrifices these
people have made and see if you can give
them and their families to thank you
they deserve definitely take a look
[Music]
you